the guardians of the galaxy might be a
fearless band of warriors but they're
also a group of serious weirdos Arrested
Development daddy issues
tragic origin stories if you can name a
serious insecurity or trauma odds are
one of them has it these are the
guardians of greatest weaknesses Peter
quill is kidnapped as a child by yondu
and his band of Ravagers right after he
watches his mother die growing up in the
company of space pirates is as thrilling
as it is terrifying ultimately stranding
him in a prolonged adolescence he gives
himself the name star-lord in order to
sound cool his tastes and interests are
static as his entire cultural education
is stuck on the awesome mix his mother
left him he is an eternal child of the
1980s stranded among aliens who've never
heard of Kevin Bacon while all of this
is endearing in its own weird way less
so is his underdeveloped emotional
intelligence Peter is incredibly
insecure he gets into fights with rocket
over who's the best pilot becomes
jealous of Thor and puts personal
satisfaction before the greater good
consistently who can forget the moment
in Avengers infinity war when he attacks
Thanos set of grieve for Gamora giving
the tyrant the opening he needs to
escape that's all part of his overall
immaturity Groot is introduced as
Rockets muscle and partner in crime
while Groot turns out to be a sensitive
creature he also seems perfectly happy
to do what everyone else is doing
especially if it allows him a relatively
easy life the adult Groot in the first
guardians film is happy to take orders
from Rocket even amid constant criticism
Groot is a useful teammate when he's
motivated but pretty useless when it
comes to everything else Groot isn't
going to come up with plans chart a new
course or even pay attention indeed when
baby Groot is asked to find a particular
item for yondu he brings back everything
imaginable but the item including a
severed human toe the one time group
thinks independently is when he
sacrifices himself at the end of
guardians of the galaxy he might not be
a great thinker planner or leader but he
loves his adoptive family and will do
anything for them
[Music]
when audiences meet Drax the destroyer
in the first guardians film all he wants
us to kill Ronan the accuser later all
he wants us to kill thanos his focus is
sharp but it also leads to trouble
while there's lack of nuance and intense
literal thinking is hilarious nothing
goes over my head my reflexes are too
fast
ketchup Drax is one-track mind gets him
and the group into trouble on more than
one occasion indeed after the guardians
plan to sell the orb to the collector
goes awry
Drax responds by calling Ronan out and
demanding a showdown he has no plan
other than to stab Ronan repeatedly this
to him is not an impediment to Drax his
credit the beatdown he receives from
Ronan does teach him to value his team
it doesn't change his approach to battle
however he's still a stabbed first ask
questions later kind of guy sometimes
this is useful but other times it leads
to trouble he's learning but he's likely
always going to be a hard-headed
goofball with too many knives in too
little caution Thanos raised Gamora to
be the perfect killing machine she grows
up stealing herself against the need for
affection striving to become her adopted
father's perfect killer she succeeds but
only at tremendous emotional cost when
Gamora finally escapes Thanos and finds
herself with the Guardians it triggers a
long suppressed need for a real family
while she complains about having to deal
with quill and Rockets adolescent antics
it's clear that she secretly delights in
scolding them the same is true of baby
Groot and even Drax she doesn't just
want to take care of them
Gamora wants them to behave the problem
is that Gamora puts everything into her
strange little family she goes from
totally closed off and selfish to
totally open and self-sacrificing that
imbalance kills her but she wouldn't
have it any other way
Thanos does one of the worst things a
parent can do to nebula and Gamora he
pits his daughters against each other
forcing them to fight for his approval
nebula tends to come out the loser in
these twisted games and it scars her for
life when she finally hunched down
Gamora
on ego and beats her in a fight nebula
celebrates like the little sister that
she is that's when she reveals that all
she's ever really wanted was a sister
this moment frees her of the need to
please Thanos now all she wants to do is
kill him in the aftermath of the snap
nebula learns how to be a good friend
instead of killing to please her father
she learns how to play paper football
and be a good sport it's not a happy
ending for the blue-skinned cyborg it is
instead her happy beginning in the
beginning of the Guardians films
yondu captures young Peter quill on
earth but decides not to bring the boy
to his father ego from quills
perspective yondu kidnaps him but in
fact the pirate was saving him from a
terrible fate as he discovered what
Eagle was really doing with his children
when the other Ravagers catch wind of
yondu's apparent human trafficking they
exile him instead of trying to find a
way to redeem himself or tell Peter the
truth
yondu doubles down on being a scoundrel
though he can never bring himself to
kill Peter when he's betrayed by him
yondu never tells him that he sees Peter
as his own son until it's nearly too
late
being unable to say he's sorry dooms him
in the end even if he manages to redeem
himself Rocket puts up a gruff
wisecracking exterior as a way of
protecting himself from his own trauma
and self-loathing even when the
Guardians accept him he still actively
antagonizes them because of how much he
hates himself it slips out occasionally
like when he gets drunk and yells his
need to push everyone away obscures the
fact that Rocket is a fierce warrior a
brilliant engineer an ace pilot and a
loyal friend rocket pushes people away
because every time he feels love and
acceptance he's reminded of how much he
thinks he doesn't deserve it
Groot is the only one he really lets in
and even then Rocket bosses him around
mantis first appears as a servant of ego
Peter Quill's father
she knows that ego was murdering his
children as part of his plan to create
one powerful enough to overrun the
galaxy with his essence however she's
too scared of ego to tell the Guardians
right away only her burgeoning
friendship with Drax moves her to tell
them what's really happening plainly put
mantis has no self-esteem and no social
skills in a group where ruthless
curry is the norm mantis instantly
becomes an easy target she's happy to
absorb it because the group accepts her
but hopefully she'll soon learn that she
doesn't have to stand for such teasing
just to enjoy the bonds of friendship
even before Asgard's destruction Thor
struggled with responsibility and
leadership the events of Avengers
infinity Wars sent him spiraling into
drunkenness in an effort to block out
his trauma and loss it's an
understandable reaction and ultimately
he redeems himself by naming Valkyrie as
the next leader of Asgard but his
underlying problems remain by the end of
Avengers endgame Thor has no real long
term goals he can do anything
but he realizes even after defeating
Thanos that he doesn't know what he
wants to do that's why he fits in so
well with the Guardians he's a screw-up
trying to figure things out just like
them will he chart a new course
alongside them hopefully yes so long as
they keep him away from the beer check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you